in several videos we have touched on the
idea of separation of powers between
three branches of government in the
united states you have the legislative
branch that writes laws and decides on
the budget for the government you have
the executive branch that runs the
actual government and then you have the
judicial branch that decides on the
constitutionality of laws and actions by
the government as well as interprets
existing laws
and connected to this idea of separation
of powers where each of these branches
are somewhat independent but not
completely independent is that they all
have checks and balances on each other
we've talked about in multiple videos
the executive can veto a law by the
legislative the legislative can override
that veto the legislative decides on the
budget that the executive has to run the
government the judicial branch decides
on constitutionality the executive
branch decides who is even going to
become a justice in the supreme court
and so when you have the separation of
powers and you have these checks and
balances it provides multiple
opportunities to influence
policy and the actions of government and
there's two ways that you could view
influence you could view it as a
positive thing after all it's government
by the people the people are sovereign
so they should be able to influence what
the government does but sometimes a
cynical view of influence is well who
gets to influence and is it really by
the people or are there other interests
maybe driven by things like money that
have undue influence but just to get a
sense of how folks can influence or
where there are points of influence is
well first what laws
what laws get passed or what gets funded
that's decided in the budget
now as an individual as a citizen you
can write letters to your congress
person you can petition them you can
call them up you can show up at town
halls that they hope that they hold in
order to speak your voice but there's
also interest groups
now interest groups could be corporate
interest groups they could be unions
they could be
professions and these interest groups
will oftentimes also lobby congress in
order to influence what gets funded or
the laws that get passed or don't get
passed and the word lobbying really is
just this idea of trying to influence
the government
now a major way a major point of
influence in the united states is when
there are elections
who actually gets elected
and so you can imagine there could be
direct support endorsement for different
candidates
money especially with mass media
becoming more and more important becomes
a bigger and bigger part of elections so
you can donate at an individual level or
you often see now and this is a very
controversial area where there is heated
debates on to what degree large
donations can be made to what degree
corporations can influence elections but
who gets elected is perhaps the biggest
lever on our government
for example even if your main concern is
judicial and the judicial is the one
branch that is most immune from
elections supreme court justices are not
elected they are appointed by the
president with approval from the senate
but if you did care who is going to be
in the judiciary well there there would
be a strong motivation to influence who
is going to be president and then even
once they are president there might be
some influence some lobbying on who they
appoint to the judiciary if a law gets
passed by congress there's still another
outlet you could petition the executive
to veto that law
so i'll leave you there the main
takeaway from this is that because of
these checks and balances and separation
of powers there's multiple levers of
influence in the government and i've
just touched on a few of them an
interesting thing to always think about
is how much of our current
levers of influence especially as they
exist today in our modern government how
much of this was intended by the
founders of our country the the authors
of the constitution and how much is
based on things that we could have never
predicted they could have never
predicted the size of the country they
could have never predicted the influence
of mass media they could have never
perhaps predicted the influence of money
who knows i will leave you with that
question